[Music]
the amazon rainforest is one of the
largest if not the largest in the world
rainforests are critically important for
the global climate in many ways
it regulates temperature and weather
cycles in the americas and it actually
carries rain to much of the continent
which is a breadbasket for the world
they have what are called flying rivers
above the jungle these bands of moisture
that really affect and regulate weather
patterns
far from the amazon
and even more critical now with climate
change the destruction of the amazon
which has been accumulating over decades
it's accelerating almost at the point of
no return
scientists are warning that we're
getting closer and closer to a tipping
point that we may even be there already
so if we pass that tipping point we
start seeing the forest turning into a
savannah
where you don't have the trees that are
able to pull all that pollution out of
the air
you don't have the ecosystem that's
producing the rainfall that feeds a
continent
brazil's government says it's working to
stop
deforestation
but behind the scenes it's
actively engaged in a campaign to
privatize and develop the amazon
and it's really being fueled and
encouraged by a government that really
believes that the amazon is there to be
developed to be privatized to be
exploited for its natural riches
unless we find a way to reduce the sort
of voracious demand in the world for the
commodities that come out of the amazon
it's really hard to see how
this cycle of destruction
will really ever end
and eventually it's going to be too late
if you want to know why the amazon is
being destroyed it's not because people
just want to destroy it it's because
they're doing it for the things that
we're consuming far far away
you have to understand it from the
perspective of certain forces in brazil
especially the forces behind
ranching and logging
you really just need to go to your local
home depot and look at the hardwoods
that are being sold there many of which
come from brazil and many which come
from the amazon and those are going on
the living room floor
or think about it the next time you have
a barbecue and you're enjoying a really
nice steak or you buy a burger well the
beef that you're eating is part of this
global beef system that starts in the
amazon
as much as the messaging is that they
don't want
people in the amazon to be burning the
amazon what the world is really telling
these people is that we will pay you
to burn the amazon because we will buy
everything that you're selling us
the amazon rainforest it's lost in the
past 40 years an area the size of
california there was progress that was
being made in slowing those burns
that's changed the burns are
accelerating this year they were at an
11-year high last year
so why isn't anyone being held
accountable
this was a story that was a year in the
making and the more i started digging it
became obvious that everyone in the
amazon region is seeking a piece of land
and grabbing a piece of public land
and the government is not only
looking the other way but in many ways
they're actually encouraging it
after spending some time on the ground
and talking to
dozens dozens and dozens of ranchers of
enforcers of park rangers of people
within bolsonaro's inner circle
it becomes clear that
everything pushes these ranchers and
these farmers towards the decisions that
they make
not only do we have the insatiable
demand for commodities but it's rooted
in brazil's culture and it's rooted in
brazil's history
[Music]
in the 70s and 80s the brazilian policy
was very much to encourage
industrialized farmers and manufacturers
into the amazon because they wanted to
develop the amazon as brazil's ticket to
first world status
this was during the brazilian miracle
years of extremely high economic growth
when
the government was calling people to the
amazon a lot of poor brazilians had been
working this land for decades and yet
they had no claim to this land and so
the policy shifted
from encouraging the big farmers and
favoring the big guy
into
let's help the little guy
and it was one of the biggest social
welfare giveaways of all time where they
started handing out government land in
the amazon to small
farmers to poor brazilians
you had tv ads you had radio ads you had
ads in magazines that drove people to
the amazon and encouraged millions of
people to move from the coastal cities
into the amazon and conquer what they
were calling the green hell
and they said it was a land without men
for men without land
that's what drove this massive migration
of people
to the amazon
to stake their claim in the amazon to
sort of be homesteaders
to
clear a piece of land
and make something of it and contribute
to this capriciously growing economy in
brazil
that message
several decades later
still persists it's very much in the
brazilian culture that in order to
prosper you need to have land
[Music]
there's almost a road map to how
deforestation happens it's a very
predictable cycle
in the amazon you have a mess of a land
management system and so there's a lot
of public land that hasn't been
designated for a specific purpose
typically poor brazilians will go in
they're the foot soldiers of
deforestation in a lot of ways they'll
claim this land they'll band together
and really
create these societies
the hardwoods are always the first to go
and so the easiest way to sort of
survive
is to get cattle and sell it to
the internal market or the global market
they don't last too long on the land
because it's uh it's very difficult to
make a living in the end and so a lot of
these families are pushed off their land
eventually or bought out of their land
and it's at that point that the big
ranchers and the big farmers come in
and they start gathering this land and
accumulating land empires and they're
able to say we didn't clear the land we
weren't the ones who burned it down
they build their empires and they start
producing soybeans coffee cacao
in brazil these are not small farmer
products
they require irrigation and investment
and they require a lot of money it's
typically the big farmers who get into
this
the bolsonaro administration
didn't invent the practice of turning a
blind eye as the amazon is rated and
granting amnesty afterwards
however the government through its
actions is accelerating those land grabs
like never before
they have stripped the regulating
agencies
of their manpower the budgets have been
cut the people in charge of land
management agencies are ranchers and
farmers who have a direct stake in
making sure that the system keeps
running and possibly most damaging is
that the government wants to amnesty
more recent invasions and bigger
invasions than ever before
scientists tell us
that this is the decisive decade
president biden in the united states
began to try to sort of pressure brazil
into doing something to rein in the
destruction of the amazon
president biden invited president
bolsonaro to a climate summit that was
held in 2021 president bolsonaro he was
defiant what he pointed to was this idea
of an amazonian paradox
what he meant by that was that brazil's
rain forest is one of the greatest
resources in the world
and yet 24 million people who live
around the amazon region they're poor
so he basically said if the united
states or any other
richer nation in the world wants brazil
to stop
deforestation they got to pay for it
just getting to the amazon is a hike i
live in sao paulo just flying there is a
really long journey
there's no cell service the roads are
terrible and so anywhere you go is is a
journey
we visit one town where this had
happened approximately 20 years ago
called
and this is a town that really didn't
exist except in the last 20 years
it was pure rainforest
and now almost 2 000 families ended up
settling there
everywhere you look you see coffee
plantations and cattle ranches and you
have thousands and thousands of farmers
who have been living on this land that
they don't have title
one of the most surprising aspects of
the journey that we took was that it's
really hard to find clear villains there
i think from the outside you look at the
amazon and you think well you know
monsters that are tearing down this
beautiful rain forest
when you get there and you start talking
to these people you realize that some of
the decisions they've made or decisions
that other people would have made if
they were in those shoes
[Music]
one of the farmers that we spent some
time with is a man named
a few decades ago he traded a motorcycle
for a plot of land and 20 years later he
has built a mini empire
he was a small farmer with 200 hectares
or so
and he'd made the transition from
cattle
to
coffee it was something he was very
proud of
one of the arguments that you hear from
environmentalists and from people
looking abroad is that there should be
sustainable ways to live in harmony with
the forest
there's no market for the products that
you make when you are producing from the
forest
fish
oily
[Music]
another man who we met was named
everardo pandorfi
he was one of the original settlers of
union bondarencis
he arrived in around 2000 with a few of
his brothers
and it was pure rainforest when they
arrived
pandori recognizes that to make a living
on the land you have to clear the land
that's just the way it is there's no
other way to do it in his view
he went for the hardwoods first because
that brings in the fast cash
he torched the scrub to clean it up and
then he put cattle on the land
that's what was repeated over and over
and again in this particular town and
it's been repeated across the amazon
and it's really a driving force behind
the deforestation that we're that we're
seeing now
on the other end of this story you have
the industrialized ranchers and farmers
some of these guys have amassed land
empires in the tens of thousands of
hectares which is possible only if you
were awarded it by the dictatorship you
bought it up from small farmers or their
land grabs themselves
one of the ranchers we met a very
successful rancher
adelio barfoldi
his history is like the history of so
many people that have settled in the
amazon he migrated to the amazon from
another part of brazil
in search of a prosperity that he
couldn't find at home
barafaldi is a staunch supporter of
bolsonaro as are most of the big
ranchers and farmers in the state and
throughout the amazon these are the guys
that bolsonaro says can solve the
problem of deforestation
and so as bolsonaro is seeking to
uh amnesty a lot of these land grabs
the biggest change that he's proposing
is allowing these big farmers who have
deforestated more recently
to apply for official title to this
amazon land
[Music]
over the years adelie barcali has
amassed over 40 000 hectares of land and
he strived to actually follow the law in
brazil
he built his cattle ranching empire on a
system that is designed to be gamed in a
way and he has actually tried
in his views to really follow the rules
in brazil that do allow you to go in and
develop a cattle ranch
he actually replanted a lot of the
preserve that he's required to have
under federal law
these are the guys that'll say that are
the biggest advocates for privatizing
the amazon
because they say they have the resources
to protect the amazon
and what you're seeing now is the land
invasion sort of flipping on its head in
that you have large
property owners who are are still
fighting for that land because they
don't actually own title to a lot of
this stuff so they're still fighting for
this land by smaller farmers who are
trying to break into their reserves and
cut down their trees
[Music]
over the years the public undesignated
land has pretty much been snapped up
what's left in the amazon are protected
parks and indigenous territories and so
those are the lands that are now under
attack
there are people that are trying to
fight this sort of
wave of
destruction as best they can
and one of them is a uh is a park ranger
we met a man named carlos hangel he's a
72 year old park ranger he's ready to
retire he's been fighting this fight for
20 years and he will plain say he's
exhausted
he dreams of retiring
to write the great brazilian novel but
he's afraid to leave his job because
he's afraid that his replacement won't
have the same sort of drive to protect
the land
he oversees a park that is twice the
size of rhode island and he does it
with
a staff of just a few people
it's basically been a long campaign to
fight back to keep back people who want
to go into his park and turn it into
cattle ranches
he goes out into the woods with his
rangers and he's hacking his way through
the woods with the machetes
[Music]
it's incredibly difficult work
because the forest you go 10 feet and
you can't see the person anymore
it's easy for them to escape
sometimes it'll take 12 hours to get 20
kilometers
we weren't able to make those journeys
because it was just so deep into the
forest that they were happening
brazil does need to resolve its land
titling system
it's a system that is so dysfunctional
that in many cases you don't know who
the real owner is
a lot of people are making a lot of
money from the dysfunctional land
management system that's in place
there's an incentive to keep that going
to
not fix this broken system because
otherwise brazil would run out of space
to
feed the world's appetite for
commodities
it's a really complicated and
nuanced phenomena
it's just not going to be solved unless
you really recognize the social economic
political and cultural forces that are
behind that drive destruction of the
amazon
you